I've built hundreds of NAND workflows
and I've taught thousands of people how
to use it and for the first time I'm
telling people to stop mostly and that's
not because NAND is bad. It's definitely
not. But something has changed over the
last 6 months which has altered the
calculus about when you should and
should not use NADN to solve your
problems. And if you're building AI
systems for yourself or for a client, it
is imperative that you understand where
that line is because it's not in the
same place it used to be. Up until about
six months ago, if you wanted to create
a complex AI automation or agent, the
answer was pretty clear as for what tool
you should use, especially if you were
non-technical, and that was NADN because
the alternatives at the time was either
writing real code or using the earlier
versions of these agent coding agents
like claude code or cursor. And now
those agentic coding agents were very
strong. But the truth was to get the
most out of them you did need to
understand how to write code. You had to
get your hands dirty very often. But now
that's completely changed because tools
like claw code, codeex, and anti-gravity
have gotten so good and so userfriendly
that you don't need to know how to code
to get the most out of these. And if you
are using those particular tools, the
ceiling for what you can do with them
has actually passed NADN. And because of
that dynamic, NAND's limitations have
become a lot harder to ignore. So in
this video, we're going to dive deep
into those limitations. So you can come
out of here with a better sense of when
NAND makes sense and when it doesn't
because this is not by any means an NAN
hit piece. Naden is simply a tool, but
we need to be educated about when Naden
is the best tool for the job and when we
should start using coding agents like
cloud code. So let's kick this off by
talking about the three primary areas
that NAD struggles when we compare it to
agentic coding agents like cloud code.
And remember it's not just cloud code.
You could insert anti-gravity, codeex,
open code, any of those, right? But I'll
continue to reference cloud code
throughout this video. Now those three
areas where naden struggles are
scalability, speed to deployment on
complex projects, and commercial
licensing. Now let's start with scaling.
And there's two parts to scaling. First
part is scaling of the project itself.
So imagine I have some sort of project
that's inside of NAND and it's now 50 or
60 nodes. Might sound extreme, but there
are use cases where we need this. And
the issue with NAN is once we get to
those wild levels of code nodes and just
nodes in general, it starts to become
rather brittle. And as it becomes more
brittle and larger in general, chances
are we're also tossing in a lot more
code nodes in our workflow itself, which
then begs the question, why are we even
in NN in the first place? But as you
take your workflow and add more deeply
nested logic, more loops, more error
handling, you begin to see some of the
issues with the NN infrastructure
because the equivalent of those 50 60
node solutions inside of NAND could very
easily just be a few hundred lines of
code inside of something like cloud code
which is much easier to test and scale.
Which brings us to the second point of
scaling and that's throughput and
thinking of how many users might be
using this thing all at once. If we're
trying to run hundreds of things in
parallel, deal with thousands of API
calls every hour and deal with very
large data sets, chances are again NAN
is going to struggle here. And the
solutions for those scenarios inside of
NAND eventually lead you towards some
hacky type things, right? Where you're
kind of going outside of the box with NN
to make it work. And when you get to the
place where you're trying to do hacky
solutions to actually solve your problem
with any again you need to ask yourself
why am I doing this and not using a tool
like cloud code and using real code to
solve the problem in the manner is meant
to be solved because when you're
handling these large complex projects
inevitably you begin to hit bottlenecks
inside of naden and there's easy
solutions inside of a normal coding
ecosystem to solve that. Now, the second
issue with NAND is its speed to
deployment when it comes to complex
projects. Now, this might surprise some
of you because speed to deployment is
kind of NAND's thing, but it's really
only Naden's thing when it's with simple
or medium difficulty projects. When
we're dealing with complex issues, the
fact is it is infinitely faster for me
to hop inside of NAND or Codeex and
prompt my way to the solution versus
going inside of NADN and trying to tie a
bunch of nodes together. And that also
includes if I'm on any cloud version,
which isn't available on the self-host,
and that's their workflow builder.
Furthermore, the output I get with real
code is going to be easier to iterate
upon, easier to test, and easier to add
things on to it later down the line.
Now, the third area where NAND struggles
is commercial licensing. And this
doesn't really get talked about enough,
and I think it's because NAD's fair use
policy is very confusing. NAD is not
open source, and I've seen it referenced
as open source by a lot of creators, and
that's simply not true. It uses a fair
use policy. Now, what does that mean?
Well, that means if I build something
that's awesome inside of any and I want
to sell it or use it as a SAS project,
well, I can, but only in certain
instances. And those instances are if my
application I built an NN does not
require the user to give me credentials.
So, imagine I built a personal
assistant. Imagine I built my version of
of OpenClaw inside of Nen. Well, that
might require you to give me your email
credentials or your Gmail credentials or
whatever credentials. can't do that
inside of NAN, right? And there's many
many scenarios you can imagine that
would require the customer to give their
credentials for whatever reason to make
the app work. You can't do that in NAND.
And what that means is you're very
limited in what you can create inside of
NAN and then turn around and make a SAS
project. So in terms of using NADN to
build something to make money, again
this falls very very short. Again,
compare that to something like cloud
code. I build it. It's my code. I can
sell it however I want. I can package it
however I want. I can take things that
are open source. Not the case with NAND.
And that's a huge issue if you're
someone who's in this to build to make
money. So those are the three areas
where NAND struggles and they're areas
that are becoming more and more apparent
in today's day and age. Now like I said
in the beginning, this is not an any hit
piece. Any is a tool and it's the best
tool for the job in many instances. But
what is its lane? When does it make
sense to use? Let's talk about that now
because I think there's three specific
places where NAND should still be your
go-to because there's still three areas
where Naden wins. Number one is its
speed to deployment with simple or
medium difficulty projects. Number two
is its accessibility for non-technical
teams and number three is its entire
integration ecosystem. So let's talk
about those. So let's start with number
one which is its speed to deployment
with simpler medium-sized projects. N is
still king here. If I want to put
together a very quick MVP with a
relatively linear idea that I know how I
want it to start from beginning to end,
I can do that in Nen in 5 10 minutes and
I can do it in a visual manner which is
very easy to both explain to a
non-technical team but also troubleshoot
and iterate upon versus if I try to do
something like that in clawed code, it
involves a lot of additional overhead
that may just not make sense at these
early stages. And that speed to
deployment on these lower level
projects, a lot of this glue work, that
sort of internal tools behind the scenes
isn't something you can dismiss out of
hand. And it is where NAD is 100% a
winner. And piggybacking off of that is
point number two, which is accessibility
to non-technical teams. And this is not
something that can be dismissed. A large
part of NAND's meteoric rise was its
accessibility. It was the ability to
allow people who weren't technical to
actually get their hands dirty and start
doing things that were completely
outside their wheelhouse a few years
ago, but were actually realistic for
them to build because it was visual,
because it was relatively simple. So, if
you're dealing with a client or a team
that is full of people who quote unquote
aren't technical, yet they need to get
hands-on on this project, may need to
edit it, may need to actually
troubleshoot it, well, NN is brilliant
for that. Versus the alternative, which
is like, hey, I built this Python app
for you. Here's the GitHub repo. Go
ahead and edit it as you need. Well,
that's a bridge too far, frankly, for
honestly 99% of the population. So if
you're building things for teams of
non-developers who do need to get
hands-on, frankly, NADN totally shines
in that department. And lastly, the
integration system of NADN is pretty
unmatched. There's what 4 500 built-in
integrations inside of NADN that is
essentially abstract away the entire
authentication process, which frankly
can be a pain in the butt even if you're
using something like cloud code. And
that integration ecosystem and that
abstraction layer is again huge for some
of this internal background glue work
that essentially keeps a lot of
businesses running with low-level
automations. So let's kind of recap
where we are in 2026 with all these
tools because the gap between NAND and
these coding agents like claude code
used to be a crack, but now it's a
canyon and it's a canyon that's getting
larger and larger. But that doesn't mean
NAND is dying. It just means nen has a
very specific lane now. And while again
6 months to 12 months ago the highway
was kind of dominated by nen well now
maybe it just has a couple lanes on the
right hand side and that's okay because
again it's a tool. You're an AI
developer. You should be somewhat tool
agnostic. We just want to solve problems
and use the correct tool for the job.
This isn't a hit on nan. This isn't me
trying to hype up cloud code. It's just
the reality. And if you want to become a
more mature AI developer, it is
imperative you understand which lane
you're in for which particular job.
Which means the true power is in knowing
how to do both. We do not want to be a
one-trick pony. But I also think it's
important to have these conversations,
especially in the AI space where these
things are just changing so so rapidly.
So that's where I'm going to leave you
for today. As always, check out the
links in the description and in the
comments if you're looking for more
resources about both Claude Code and NNN
because I think they still have a ton of
value no matter where you are in your AI
journey. Tons of resources in the free
school. I also have Chase AI Plus which
is if you're a little more serious about
this and you're trying to figure out,
hey, how can I actually use these skills
to make money? So, make sure to check
that out as well. And as always, I'll
see you